trois jours avant l'ouverture du procès
de klaus barbie devant la cour d'assises
de lyon parmi les nombreuses analyses
publiées nous a semblé intéressant ce
soir avec betty 0 et françois granier
d'évoquer la personnalité de barbie
comment est il devenu un petit chef nazi
betty du rau a fait appel notamment un
homme résistants allemands qui fûtes
interprète au procès de nuremberg
un vrai 1933 klaus barbie 20 ans
s'inscrit au générique aériennes comme
la plupart de ses jeunes compatriotes
cette adhésion marque pour lui le début
de son activité politique
ss en septembre 1935
klaus barbie adhère au parti nazi en 37
sous le numéro 4 millions 583 milles
0,85
né dans une famille catholique et
villageoises il passe une enfance de
petit allemands ordinaires sous la
férule d'un père instituteur il admire
pour sa conduite pendant la guerre de 14
mai le craint pour sa rudesse et ses
violences de buveurs l'amour de ce père
en 33 empêche qu aux barbies
d'entreprendre des études supérieures et
le pousse à chercher une autre voie de
promotion sociale les national
socialisme sera sa chance je dirais le
lachance dû rater parce que c'était
caractéristique le sa lutte tous ces
gens là on les a vus là après l'autre au
banc des accusés a dû rambert c'était
des petites gens avec des petits
sentiment d'un md fidélité avec beaucoup
de sentimentalité sont de véritables
sentiments une bande d'inviter des gens
sont véritables carrières des gens de
caractère dont vers gurs moins que
moyenne et vous assimilez parfaitement
barbie à ces gens là
voilà la conclusion je pense
son le connaître les détails que barbie
était tout à fait approprié dès
l'origine dès le début de sa carrière à
ce genre de d'action et de crimes
auxquels il s'est adonné